This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So years ago I was talking to John Marr. He's the guy who first uttered this bedrock 99PI mantra. Always rate the plaque. And we were talking about the show and he said, you know what you should do a story about. It's one of my favorite places in San Francisco. So I went to the address and I checked it out. And I kid you not. He sent me to a gas station on Van S Avenue in San Francisco. He told me to look around and discover what was weird about it.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几年前，我和约翰·马尔交谈。他就是最初说出这句99PI核心口号的人：“永远要给牌匾评分”。当时我们正在聊这个节目，他说，你知道你应该做一个什么样的故事吗？这是我在旧金山最喜欢的地方之一。于是我去了那个地址，一探究竟。我没骗你，他把我带到了旧金山范内斯大道上的一家加油站。他让我四处看看，找出它有什么奇怪的地方。
In almost every respect, it's a normal Chevron gas station. It has a blue awning and the red and blue Chevron logo on the sign, but the sign in awning don't say Chevron, they say, standard. As in standard oil, the massive oil monopoly broken up in the early 20th century by the Sherman Antitrust Act. One of the independent companies created by that breakup was Chevron, and for some reason, even though this gas station is a modern Chevron station in every way, it's called Standard. If you call the station, they will answer the phone,
在几乎所有方面，它都是一家普通的雪佛龙加油站。它有蓝色的遮阳篷，标志上有红蓝相间的雪佛龙标志，但标志和遮阳篷上写的不是“雪佛龙”，而是“标准”。就像标准石油公司，那家在20世纪初被《谢尔曼反托拉斯法》拆分的庞大石油垄断企业。雪佛龙是那次拆分中产生的独立公司之一，出于某种原因，尽管这家加油站从各方面看都是现代雪佛龙加油站，但它却叫“标准”。如果你给这个加油站打电话，他们会接听，
saying Chevron, and the attendant cannot tell you why it's a standard on the side of Tride. But a trademark lawyer, like Amanda Levindowski, can. A trademark can be any word name symbol device used by someone who has the keyword here is bonafide intent to use the mark in commerce and they're using that word symbol device to identify the source of their goods or services. That phrase bonafide intent means that if you want to keep a trademark, you have to use it. In this particular case, when standard oil was busted up,
说“雪佛龙”，而服务员无法告诉你为什么侧面写着“标准”。但像阿曼达·莱文多夫斯基这样的商标律师可以。商标可以是任何文字、名称、符号或装置，只要使用者有——这里的关键词是——在商业中使用该标志的“善意”，并且他们使用该文字、符号或装置来识别其商品或服务的来源。那句“善意”意味着如果你想保留一个商标，你就必须使用它。在这个特定案例中，当标准石油公司被拆分时，
the standard oil trademark still retained a lot of goodwill and value. And if for whatever reason down the line, Chevron wants to take advantage of that value, the name standard has to be used. And it has to be used in connection with whatever the underlying goods or services are. So they couldn't just print pamphlets that occasionally used mixed Chevron standard branding
“标准石油”商标仍然保留了大量的商誉和价值。如果出于某种原因，雪佛龙想要利用这种价值，就必须使用“标准”这个名称。而且它必须与任何潜在的商品或服务相关联。所以他们不能只是印一些偶尔混合使用雪佛龙和标准品牌的小册子，
and say that they were still using it for oil and gas. They have to prominently use the standard name in conjunction with oil and gas services if they want to keep it. So that's why there's a standard gas station that for all intents and purposes operates as a chevron station in San Francisco and 15 other locations in the US.
然后说他们还在将其用于石油和天然气。如果他们想保留这个名称，就必须在石油和天然气服务中显著地使用“标准”这个名字。这就是为什么在旧金山和美国其他15个地方，有一家实际上作为雪佛龙加油站运营的“标准”加油站。
This week, you should do a story for researching and presenting short design stories requested by our listeners and seeing where that path takes us. And in the spirit of the exercise, we're starting with what I think is the most requested design topic of all time. Here's our digital director Kurt Colstad talking with me about desire paths. And as the name suggests, desire paths are these unplanned routes, the people just really want to take.
本周，你应该做一个关于研究和展示听众要求的简短设计故事，并看看这条路会把我们带向何方。本着这种练习的精神，我们从我认为有史以来被要求最多的设计主题开始。这是我们的数字总监库尔特·科尔斯塔德和我讨论“欲望路径”。顾名思义，欲望路径就是那些人们真正想走的、未经规划的路线。
And they're shaped by repeated use. And I think part of it is that they're found everywhere. You can just see them all over the place. And the most common type that you see are shortcuts, which are often just visible as rough dirt trails through, you know, grassy areas and cities. So most commonly when you think of a desir, you think of like, imagine a circuitous, or maybe like a 90 degree turn and a sidewalk, and then there's this like 45 degree dirt path
它们是由反复使用形成的。我认为部分原因是它们随处可见。你可以在很多地方看到它们。你看到的最常见的类型是捷径，通常表现为穿过城市草地的粗糙土路。所以当你想到欲望路径时，最常见的是，想象一个迂回的，或者可能是90度转弯的人行道，然后有一条45度的土路，
that cuts across and creates a shortcut. And that's the most common idea of what a desire path is. Those people wanna take the shortest path, but desire paths are not always a shortcut. In fact, sometimes they end up being a long cut. And this can happen for all kinds of reasons. And in some places, there are superstitions about walking under utility poles.
它横穿过去并形成了一条捷径。这就是关于欲望路径最常见的概念。人们想走最短的路径，但欲望路径并不总是捷径。事实上，有时它们最终会变成长路。这可能由各种原因造成。在某些地方，人们对在电线杆下行走有迷信。
And so people end up taking this long way around, and you can see that marked in the dirt. Or when there's a slope going down to a crossover underneath a road, and normally, a biker would bike down that hill and then bike back up the other side. But often, there's like a way to just, you know, take the grass and go off to the side and it ends up being a longer path.
所以人们最终绕了远路，你可以在泥土上看到这种痕迹。或者当有一条通往道路下方交叉口的斜坡时，通常骑自行车的人会骑下那个坡，然后再骑上另一边。但通常，有一种方法可以，你知道，走草地绕到一边，结果却是一条更长的路。
But, you know, if they don't have to go open down the hill. Right. So it's still like a shortcut in the sense of energy. Right. It'll take them less work ultimately. But it also, it's just kind of weird because it bows out to the side And that's not how we normally think of these things. We normally think of them. That's just like yeah, the short way across So these can be really frustrating as an urban planner because a lot of reason you design things the way you do is to use the built environment to shape the behavior you want
但是，你知道，如果他们不必上下坡的话。对，所以从能量的角度来看，它仍然像一条捷径。最终会让他们少费点力。但这也有点奇怪，因为它向侧面弯曲，这并不是我们通常思考这些事物的方式。我们通常认为它们就是“穿过那里的捷径”。所以作为城市规划者，这些可能会非常令人沮丧，因为你这样设计很多东西的原因是利用建筑环境来塑造你想要的行为，
but Desire past can also be illuminating because They can really show a designer how to make their design work better for people. Right. Sometimes they frustrate the plans of urban planners and trail makers, but other times these people can actually evaluate the behaviors that people have naturally and use that to inform their designs. So, for example, college campuses have been known to map out a basic grid of sidewalks, but then leave some sidewalks unpaived and just sort of see where people walk to fill in the gaps. And then they come back in and they pave that based on the natural
但欲望路径也可以起到启发作用，因为它们真的可以向设计师展示如何让他们的设计更好地为人们服务。对。有时它们会挫败城市规划者和步道建设者的计划，但有时这些人实际上可以评估人们自然产生的行为，并利用这些信息来完善他们的设计。例如，大学校园通常会规划出基本的人行道网格，但会留下一些人行道不铺设，只是观察人们在哪里行走来填补空白。然后他们会回来，根据那些行走的人的自然行为来铺设路面。
behavior of those people walking. And in Finland, park planners have been known to watch and see where people walk after a big snow fall. So there's sort of a blank slate and people cross the park and they just trace their paths then use that to inform like a year-round pathway for that park. Oh, that's so cool. Which actually reminds me of my favorite form of snow-based desire path, the Sneckdown, which is this portmanteau of snowy and neck down, which is a neck down is actually kind of hard to picture.
在芬兰，公园规划者会观察人们在大雪过后在哪里行走。所以这就像一张白纸，人们穿过公园，他们只是追踪他们的路径，然后用这些信息来为那个公园规划全年的路径。哦，那太酷了。这实际上让我想起了我最喜欢的基于雪的欲望路径形式——“雪颈缩”（Sneckdown），这是“雪”（snowy）和“颈缩”（neck down）的合成词，颈缩实际上有点难想象。
It's like a part of the curb. Like if you can imagine like a straight street and then like a little bit of a bump out of the curb and extension of the curb is called a neck down. So how do the people use a snack down in particular? So like those finish park planners that are evaluating where people walk after snowfalls, urban planners can use snack downs to evaluate where cars walk after snowfalls, urban planners can use snack downs to evaluate where cars drive after a snowfall. And more specifically, they can look at where they don't drive.
它就像路缘的一部分。就像如果你能想象一条笔直的街道，然后路缘有一个小小的凸起，路缘的延伸就叫颈缩。那么人们具体是如何使用雪颈缩的呢？就像那些评估大雪后人们在哪里行走的芬兰公园规划者一样，城市规划者可以使用雪颈缩来评估大雪后汽车在哪里行驶。更具体地说，他们可以观察汽车不走的地方。
So when the fresh snow covers the road, drivers tend to follow a narrower path, and then other cars follow in that narrower path, which leaves a lot of area actually untouched. And this results in what is effectively like a temporary curb extension and can also form sort of traffic islands in the middle of streets where cars just don't go.
所以当新雪覆盖道路时，司机倾向于跟随一条更窄的路径，然后其他汽车跟随在那条更窄的路径上，这留下了很多实际上未被触及的区域。这导致了实际上像临时路缘延伸的效果，也可以在街道中间形成某种交通岛，汽车根本不去那里。
But then did they ever take this information and like use it for other parts of the year when it isn't snowy? That's really the key is urban planners can evaluate where people don't go and use that information to advocate for curb extensions and traffic islands where they don't go and use that information to advocate for curb extensions and traffic islands where they don't it currently exist. And the argument is pretty straightforward. I mean, if the cars don't need to go there in the winter, why did they need to go there at all, right? Right. That's smart. I like it. It gives you a little sandbox to play in once the snow falls and all of sudden, you realize that you have this opportunity to replay in your city in these little tiny ways.
但他们是否曾经获取这些信息，并将其用于一年中不下雪的其他时候？这才是关键，城市规划者可以评估人们不去的地方，并利用这些信息来倡导在目前不存在路缘延伸和交通岛的地方建立它们。这个论点非常直接。我的意思是，如果汽车在冬天不需要去那里，为什么它们根本需要去那里呢，对吧？对。这很聪明。我喜欢它。它给了你一个小沙盒，一旦下雪，你突然意识到你有机会以这些微小的方式重新规划你的城市。
A lot of this analysis is really kind of lovely. It's like people go out and they take pictures and they make videos and then they trace over these places where the cars don't go and suddenly becomes very clear. The cars don't actually need that space. One of the reasons why desire paths and snack downs are so they resonate so much with audience and not because they're urban planners. It's because they're this great metaphor for design in general. Yes, and a lot of people use them in usability design and think about them in terms of interface design. So a really common tactic is to not just decide
很多这种分析真的很可爱。就像人们走出去，拍照，拍视频，然后描绘出汽车不去的地方，突然间变得非常清楚。汽车实际上并不需要那个空间。欲望路径和雪颈缩之所以能引起观众如此强烈的共鸣，并不是因为他们是城市规划者。而是因为它们是通用设计的绝佳隐喻。是的，很多人在可用性设计中使用它们，并从界面设计的角度思考它们。所以一个非常常见的策略不是仅仅决定，
we're gonna make this thing this way and people are gonna have to use it this way, but instead to actually look at how people are already using something, and then take that and give it a more official way to work. So, for example, on Twitter, you know, ads and hashtags, those weren't built in with Twitter, users of all those over time. And then Twitter originally said, oh, well, if users are using them, we're going to support this usage and, you know, evolve what they can do.
“我们要这样制造这个东西，人们将不得不这样使用它”，而是实际上观察人们已经在使用某种东西的方式，然后采取这种方式并给它一个更正式的工作方式。例如，在Twitter上，你知道，@和标签，它们并不是Twitter内置的，用户随着时间的推移使用了所有这些。然后Twitter最初说，哦，好吧，如果用户正在使用它们，我们将支持这种用法，并且，你知道，发展它们的功能。
And never really thought about that, that ads and hashtags were basically desirpaths created by the user. Digital desirpaths. If you want to take a deeper dive into the hash mark, or octathorp is a vertical it, Avery Trollman did a whole episode about its origins, so if you turn your Himnales to episode number 145, you will find it. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the
从来没想过这一点，@和标签基本上是用户创造的欲望路径。数字欲望路径。如果你想深入了解井号，或者“八角星”（octathorp）是一个垂直的它，艾弗里·特罗尔曼做了一整集关于它起源的节目，所以如果你把你的赞美诗集翻到第145集，你就会找到它。我将更多地关注故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的
story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the
故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的
story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story. I'm going to be a little bit more focused on the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the story of the Yeah, so this was after a recent live show that we did in LA, a fan came up to me and he was like, nice job. Also, I have a story idea for you. So I was like, lay it on me and he started telling
故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事。我将更多地关注故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的故事的……是的，这是我们在洛杉矶最近的一次现场演出之后，一位粉丝走过来对我说，干得好。另外，我有一个故事点子给你。所以我说，告诉我吧，他开始告诉我
me about it and it was like about electrical current clocks and this time in Southern California when people had to make this big switch. I don't know. I didn't absorb that much of it at the time. But it did sound neat. It did kind of sound like a Bar Alley. So I went back. I started looking into it. And basically, the story starts back in the late 1800s when the Los Angeles area and sort of surrounding
关于它，它就像是关于电流时钟，以及南加州人们不得不做出这个重大转变的那个时期。我不知道。当时我没有吸收太多。但它听起来确实不错。它听起来确实有点像巴尔巷。所以我回去查了一下。基本上，这个故事始于19世纪末，当时洛杉矶地区和南加州周围的一些城镇，
to other towns in Southern California. We're starting to get their first power plants. And the main motivation at the time was to bring refrigeration to the citrus growers. So they could put oranges inside of refrigerators? Exactly, for cold orange juice. Of course. And so back in these early days of electricity,
开始拥有他们的第一批发电厂。当时的主要动机是为柑橘种植者提供制冷。所以他们可以把橙子放进冰箱里？没错，为了冰镇橙汁。当然。所以在电力发展的早期，
there wasn't a national standard for like what frequency of current these power plants should deliver us. What is an electrical frequency really mean? and what are the options that they have to work with when it comes to electrical frequencies? Okay, now the part of the show where I explain electricity. No, I don't want to actually do the complete disservice of talking too much about the physics of electricity, but the way I understand it is that electricity
对于这些发电厂应该提供什么频率的电流，并没有国家标准。电频率到底意味着什么？当涉及到电频率时，他们有什么选择？好吧，现在是节目中我解释电力的部分。不，我不想真的做那种谈论太多电力物理学的完全不称职的事情，但我理解的方式是，电力
basically comes into our homes in waves of alternating current, and you can actually think of them like pulses. And the number of pulses per second is the frequency of the current. So if you're on a 50 cycle system or like a 50 hertz system, the pulses are coming at 50 a second and then 60 hertz would be 60 a second. And 50 and 60 are sort of the two most common frequencies. And why would you use one like instead of the other? Like what determines whether or not you're going to use one or the other? They're both fine. They both do all the things we need them to do. And you can deliver current at lots of different frequencies. But if you slow it down enough, like say, to 30 hertz, when you screw in a light bulb,
基本上是以交流电波的形式进入我们的家庭，你实际上可以把它们想象成脉冲。每秒的脉冲数就是电流的频率。所以如果你在一个50周期的系统或50赫兹的系统上，脉冲每秒有50个，然后60赫兹就是每秒60个。50和60是两种最常见的频率。为什么你会使用一种而不是另一种？比如是什么决定了你是否要使用其中一种？它们都很好。它们都能完成我们需要它们做的所有事情。你可以以许多不同的频率输送电流。但如果你把它减慢到足够慢，比如30赫兹，当你拧上灯泡时，
you apparently can actually perceive a sort of that pulsing and it sort of is perceived as like a flicker in the light bulb. So in the early 1900s, Southern California, so like Los Angeles, Burbank, Pasadena, they all start kind of getting on this like 50 Hertz system. And meanwhile, the rest of the country is getting on a 60 Hertz system for the most part. And there's like some exceptions.
你显然可以感知到那种脉冲，它在灯泡中被感知为一种闪烁。所以在20世纪初，南加州，比如洛杉矶、伯班克、帕萨迪纳，都开始使用这种50赫兹的系统。与此同时，全国其他地区大部分都在使用60赫兹的系统。并且有一些例外。
Right. And so right now that's not that big a deal in the early 1900s, but eventually this grid is they're going to all meet up and that would not be good to have two different systems. Right. And so it starts to become a problem. And one of the things that becomes a problem is like manufacturers had to make different products for people in Southern California. Because anything with like an electrical motor that was designed to work on a 60 cycle system is not going to work as well on a 50 cycle system. And one of the things that definitely didn't work as well
对。所以现在在20世纪初，这并不是什么大不了的事，但最终这个电网将会全部连接起来，拥有两个不同的系统是不好的。对。所以它开始成为一个问题。其中一个成为问题的事情是，制造商必须为南加州的人们制造不同的产品。因为任何设计用于60周期系统的带电动机的东西在50周期系统上都无法很好地工作。其中一个肯定无法很好工作的东西，
was electric clocks. So if you had a clock that you got in New York City and then you moved to LA and you plug in your clock, it would actually lose 10 minutes every hour. Yeah. And that is because electric clocks actually use those pulses of current to keep track of the time You know some clocks have pendulums, but keeping track of those pulses of current is it is the way that electric clocks know what time it is
就是电钟。所以如果你在纽约市买了一个时钟，然后搬到洛杉矶，插上你的时钟，它实际上每小时会慢10分钟。对。这是因为电钟实际上使用那些电流脉冲来跟踪时间。你知道有些时钟有摆锤，但跟踪那些电流脉冲是电钟知道现在几点的方式，
Or when to move the second hand And at that point electric clocks were really popular like a lot of people have them They're not quite as common anymore. So yeah, clocks were a problem. Other things with motors. And then in the 30s, California started to receive power from new dams, like the Hoover Dam. And this power was coming into California at the wrong frequency. And then the power companies would have to convert it. And the conversion process was difficult and expensive. So in 1936, the city of Los Angeles decided to switch all their customers to 60-cycle current and then in 1945, the Southern California Edison company decided to switch everyone else
或者何时移动秒针。而在那时，电钟非常受欢迎，很多人都有。它们现在没那么常见了。所以是的，时钟是个问题。其他带电动机的东西也是。然后在30年代，加州开始从胡佛大坝等新水坝接收电力。这种电力以错误的频率进入加州。然后电力公司不得不转换它。转换过程既困难又昂贵。所以1936年，洛杉矶市决定将所有客户切换到60周期电流，然后在1945年，南加州爱迪生公司决定将南加州的其他所有人
in Southern California over to the 60-cycle current. And that must have been crazy because you're talking about every appliance that plugs into a wall. It is now like being run at a sub-optimal frequency and therefore you have to change everything along the way. Yeah, it was nuts. It was a huge undertaking. They weren't just like, okay, sorry, like throw out your stuff. They sent crews into people's homes to retrofit their washing machines. They sent people into factories to make sure all the machinery worked right. And it was hundreds of thousands of customers, like I think nearly a million customers. And then the power companies also had to change all their own equipment, all the electric meters.
切换到60周期电流。那一定很疯狂，因为你在谈论每一个插在墙上的电器。它现在以次优频率运行，因此你必须沿途更换所有东西。是的，太疯狂了。这是一项巨大的工程。他们不是说，好吧，抱歉，扔掉你的东西。他们派工作人员到人们家里去改造他们的洗衣机。他们派人到工厂去确保所有机器都能正常工作。那是几十万客户，我想有近一百万客户。然后电力公司也必须更换他们自己的所有设备，所有的电表。
The power companies also had to change all their own equipment, all the electric meters. And then for clocks, you could actually go and drop your clock off at something called a clock depot. And there were just like rows and rows and tables of clocks being worked on and sort of men sitting there working to make your clock work. That was a good old days. When you had this big infrastructure project and then everyone just got to work and made it work for everybody.
电力公司也必须更换他们自己的所有设备，所有的电表。然后对于时钟，你实际上可以去把你的时钟送到一个叫“时钟仓库”的地方。那里有成排成排的桌子，上面放着正在修理的时钟，男人们坐在那里工作，让你的时钟正常运转。那是美好的旧时光。当你有一个大型基础设施项目，然后每个人都投入工作，并为每个人解决问题。
Yeah, I have no idea how many people they employed for this, but it sounds like quite a few. So by 1948, all of Southern California had switched to the new system. And the final tally was like 500,000 clocks and almost 400,000 lighting fixtures, 58,000 refrigerators. And if you think of how the population of LA exploded in the following years, it's so lucky that they decided to take this on when they did.
是的，我不知道他们为此雇佣了多少人，但听起来不少。所以到1948年，整个南加州都切换到了新系统。最终统计结果是大约50万个时钟，近40万个照明装置，58,000台冰箱。如果你考虑到洛杉矶的人口在随后的几年里是如何爆炸式增长的，他们决定在那个时候承担这项任务真是太幸运了。
I mean, you couldn't possibly do it now. No, like no way. And that's sort of why you'll never see like an international standard for electrical current. So you may know if you've traveled to Europe that you have to buy like a little adapter, because most of Europe is still on a 50 cycle system. And they'll never change, because it would just be too much. It would just be too much. And I think the United States and Mexico
我的意思是，你现在根本不可能做到这一点。不，绝对不可能。这就是为什么你永远不会看到像电流这样的国际标准。所以如果你去过欧洲，你可能知道你必须买一个小适配器，因为欧洲大部分地区仍然使用50周期系统。而且他们永远不会改变，因为那将是太大的工程。那将是太大的工程。我认为美国和墨西哥，
and most of like Central America, maybe South America are 60 cycle. And Japan is actually, I think, the only country that still uses two different frequencies in their one country. So basically, one half of the country has 50 hearts and the other half is using 60 hearts. Well, that must be such a pain. Yeah, it actually was a really big problem
以及大部分中美洲，也许南美洲是60周期。而日本实际上，我认为，是唯一一个在同一个国家仍然使用两种不同频率的国家。所以基本上，国家的一半有50赫兹，另一半使用60赫兹。好吧，那一定很麻烦。是的，这实际上是一个非常大的问题，
after the Fukushima accident, because a big portion of the country lost power, there was a tsunami, and they were trying to send power from one part of the country to the other, which is a fairly common thing that we do, but they couldn't do it. You can convert from one frequency to another, but it's hard to do it in really big quantities.
在福岛事故之后，因为该国很大一部分地区断电，发生了海啸，他们试图将电力从该国的一个部分输送到另一个部分，这是我们经常做的事情，但他们做不到。你可以从一种频率转换到另一种频率，但很难以非常大的数量进行。
And so every so often in Japan, actually, there'll be this little movement that bubbles up that's like, we should all be on the same frequency. And then it just like really quickly dies because like one side is like well, we're not gonna switch And the other side's like well, we're definitely not gonna switch either and then that's the end of that So it stays the same and so it stays the same and yeah, we just can think those early Pioneers and LA that were like let's go ahead and do this before things are just out of control. Yeah, thanks Those guys. And thanks to Jake Kennen for suggesting the story for us.
所以每隔一段时间，在日本，实际上会冒出这种小运动，说我们都应该使用相同的频率。然后它很快就消失了，因为一边说“好吧，我们不会切换”，另一边说“好吧，我们肯定也不会切换”，然后事情就结束了。所以它保持不变，是的，我们只能感谢那些早期的洛杉矶先驱，他们说，让我们在事情失控之前去做吧。是的，感谢那些人。也感谢杰克·肯南建议我们做这个故事。
Yeah, thank you, Jake Kennen. And you talked to a couple other people that you want to thank. I talked to a whoreologist named Ken Rindell for this story. I thought the story was actually going to be more about clocks than it ended up being, so I learned all about how electro clocks work. Anyway, he was great. He held me in town. I asked him if he heard S-Town. He said no. Of course, I immediately sent him a link. And then I also talked to an electrical engineer named Darryl Heinrich, who was also really, really helpful. So for a long time Kurt Colstead has been obsessed with European style tilt and turn windows.
是的，谢谢你，杰克·肯南。你还和另外几个人谈过，你想感谢他们。我为这个故事采访了一位钟表学家肯·林德尔。我以为这个故事实际上会比最终呈现的更多关于时钟的内容，所以我了解了所有关于电钟如何工作的信息。无论如何，他很棒。他帮了我。我问他是否听说过《S-Town》。他说没有。当然，我立刻发给了他一个链接。然后我还采访了一位名叫达里尔·海因里希的电气工程师，他也非常有帮助。所以很长一段时间以来，库尔特·科尔斯塔德一直痴迷于欧式倾斜和旋转窗。
Really ever since he was a kid living in Biroit, Germany, I can't really explain them in audio, but they're really functional and worthy of his design obsession. So Kurt wrote about them recently on the website, and several readers shared and appreciated his design obsession, and to some, they were completely new. And then there was a bunch of Europeans who were just confused because they didn't understand
真的，自从他小时候住在德国拜罗伊特以来，我无法在音频中解释它们，但它们非常实用，值得他的设计痴迷。所以库尔特最近在网站上写了关于它们的文章，几位读者分享并欣赏了他的设计痴迷，对一些人来说，它们是全新的。然后有一群欧洲人感到困惑，因为他们不明白
that these windows weren't already everywhere. Half the readers were astonished these things exist and wanted to have them, and the other half were shocked that anybody would think that they were shocking because they were totally ordinary everyday window designs for them. So this web article prompted a bunch of our audience to send in suggestions for other clever, regional design solutions that we should also do a story about. One of the things that somebody suggested right off the bat, which I was instantly fascinated
这些窗户不是已经随处可见了吗。一半的读者对这些东西的存在感到惊讶并想要拥有它们，而另一半则对任何人认为它们令人震惊感到震惊，因为对他们来说，它们是完全普通、日常的窗户设计。所以这篇网络文章促使我们的一大批观众发送了关于其他聪明的、区域性设计解决方案的建议，我们也应该做一个关于它们的故事。有人立刻建议的一件事，我立刻被迷住了，
by, are these things called finished, disstrying closets. They're also known as disstrying cabinets. Okay, so I'm gonna try to pronounce it. It's Austion Kui Val Scapi. Austion Kui Val Scapi, that's what it's called. That's what it's called.
是这些被称为芬兰碗碟干燥柜的东西。它们也被称为碗碟干燥柜。好吧，我要试着发音。它是“Astiankuivauskaappi”。“Astiankuivauskaappi”，这就是它的名字。这就是它的名字。
Austion Kui Val Scapi, I can't do it. Austion Kui Val Scapi. Yes. Okay,. Astion, Kooi Valskampi. Yes. Okay, so go ahead. So, the design has a pretty simple premise. If dishes can dry themselves in storage, there's no need to dry them manually. So instead of having a drying rack next year's sink, you put your dishes away in a cabinet above the sink, and this cabinet has special shelves with slots, so the waterfalls down
“Astiankuivauskaappi”，我做不到。“Astiankuivauskaappi”。是的。好吧，“Astiankuivauskaappi”。是的。好吧，继续。所以，这个设计有一个非常简单的前提。如果碗碟可以在储存时自行干燥，就没有必要手动干燥它们。所以，与其在水槽旁边放一个干燥架，你把碗碟放进水槽上方的柜子里，这个柜子有带槽的特殊架子，所以水流下来，
through each level. And it lands ultimately in the sink or on a slope surface which then drains into that sink. And as a nice sort of design byproduct, this ends up clearing up clutter in your kitchen, so you don't have this annoying, destroying rack that's always half full of dishes sitting next to your sink.
穿过每一层。它最终落在水槽里或倾斜的表面上，然后排入那个水槽。作为一个很好的设计副产品，这最终清理了你厨房里的杂乱，所以你不会在水槽旁边放着这个总是半满碗碟的烦人的干燥架。
So your destroying rack is essentially the same cabinet you put your dishes away in. Exactly, it's a one step process. You just, you know, take the dishes, put them away, they drive themselves. I love it. It's so beautifully simple. They should do that everywhere. That's for sure. We should have those everywhere. So this regional design masterpiece was suggested by Anton Hegman. Now that he lives abroad, Anton says, I have to dry my dishes on a rack that sits on the counter like a barbarian. It's true Anton, I agree with you.
所以你的干燥架本质上就是你存放碗碟的同一个柜子。没错，这是一个一步到位的过程。你只是，你知道，拿走碗碟，把它们放好，它们自己就干了。我喜欢它。它如此美丽而简单。他们应该在任何地方都这样做。那是肯定的。我们应该在任何地方都有这些。所以这个区域性设计杰作是由安东·赫格曼建议的。现在他住在国外，安东说，我必须像个野蛮人一样在柜台上放的架子上干燥我的碗碟。是真的，安东，我同意你的看法。
We are barbarians. So you wrote an article about that one, it was a huge hit, and then it caused people to send in other little regional design solutions. And suddenly I had a lot of regional design solutions to work with. And one of the first ones that came out was this Kotatsu table, which is a Japanese furnishing that doubles as a heating fixture. So a picture a really tall coffee table with a quilt over the sides that you put your legs under. And underneath these tables there's a small space heater. And this top layer of the table, it's a little hard picture,
我们是野蛮人。所以你写了一篇关于那个的文章，它非常受欢迎，然后它导致人们发送了其他小的区域性设计解决方案。突然间，我有很多区域性设计解决方案可以使用。首先出现的是这种“炬燵”（Kotatsu）桌，这是一种兼作加热装置的日本家具。所以想象一张非常高的咖啡桌，侧面有被子，你可以把腿放在下面。在这些桌子下面有一个小型空间加热器。桌子的这一顶层，有点难想象，
but just like two panels sandwich this blanket. So you have a surface that you can set things on, but you also have this blanket, you know, or comfort or extending out on all sides. Instead of sitting around in an arc facing a fireplace, you can actually sit around in a circle and face each other and pull up sections of this cover and then sort of interact around this central heating element. Why is this a Japanese thing? So, these historically been really useful in Japan specifically because home insulation is often sparse and whole house heating can be difficult and expensive.
但就像两块面板夹住这条毯子。所以你有一个可以放东西的表面，但你也有这条毯子，你知道，或者舒适物延伸到四面八方。与其围成弧形面对壁炉坐着，你实际上可以围成一个圆圈面对面坐着，拉起这个盖子的部分，然后在中央加热元件周围互动。为什么这是日本的东西？所以，这些在历史上在日本特别有用，因为房屋隔热通常很稀疏，全屋供暖可能既困难又昂贵。
And then traditional Japanese clothing also lends itself especially well to this form of space heating because warm air can flow up through the folds of a spacious kimono and then out the neck and armholes. I mean, that's sort of what I like about it. It has a lot of very specific reasons that it comes out of Japan. Yeah. But a lot of those aren't necessary to it function either.
而且传统的日本服装也非常适合这种空间加热形式，因为暖空气可以通过宽敞和服的褶皱向上流动，然后从领口和袖孔出来。我的意思是，这就是我喜欢它的地方。它有很多非常具体的原因，所以它出自日本。是的。但其中许多对于它的功能来说也不是必要的。
A lot of those things would work for really any place or culture. But the way that it's optimized for a kimono suggests that it didn't used to be electric heating elements underneath. No, historically, they came from a food cooking system that was in the floor. They had these charcoal burning food cookers on the floor, and this morphed into a system where they would try to use that to heat the home. And then eventually, you know, in the modern era, this sort of more dangerous prone to fire solution was replaced by an electrical heating system. Right. Cool.
很多这些东西在任何地方或文化中都能发挥作用。但它为和服优化的方式表明，它过去并不是底下的电加热元件。不，历史上，它们来自地板上的食物烹饪系统。他们在地板上有这些烧木炭的食物炊具，这演变成了一个系统，他们试图用它来加热房屋。然后最终，你知道，在现代，这种更容易引发火灾的解决方案被电气加热系统所取代。对。酷。
What are those called again? Kotatsu tables. Kotatsu tables. So these would be great everywhere, as long as you didn't burn your legs. Is there any incidents that you read about anything about people burning their legs? Oh, yeah. Like, their advisory is to say, like, don't fall asleep under your Kotatsu table. Like, you can definitely, like, lead to injuries and things.
那些叫什么来着？炬燵桌。炬燵桌。所以这些在任何地方都会很棒，只要你不烧伤你的腿。你读到过关于人们烧伤腿的任何事件吗？哦，是的。比如，他们的建议是说，不要在你的炬燵桌下睡着。比如，你绝对可以，比如，导致受伤之类的事情。
Yeah, that's not a perfect design. It's not a perfect design solution. It's not a perfect design solution, but you also just shouldn't sleep under tables in general, probably so. So, especially not hot tables. Especially not hot tables. So it's really important to use the catatonic table as described, but that is not like our next design solution,
是的，那不是一个完美的设计。它不是一个完美的设计解决方案。它不是一个完美的设计解决方案，但你通常也不应该在桌子下睡觉，所以。所以，尤其是不要在热桌子下。尤其是不要在热桌子下。所以使用所描述的炬燵桌非常重要，但这不像我们的下一个设计解决方案，
which one of its powers is the versatility of this object. It's called the Hills Heist. The Hills Heist is effectively the opposite use case. It can be used for everything that it's not designed for. So we'll describe the Hills Heist. Basically, it's a rotating clothesline. It has a central metal pole that sticks up from the ground, like the trunk of a tree,
它的力量之一是这个物体的多功能性。它叫“希尔斯升降机”（Hills Hoist）。希尔斯升降机实际上是相反的用例。它可以用于它未被设计用于的所有事情。所以我们将描述希尔斯升降机。基本上，它是一个旋转晾衣绳。它有一个从地面伸出的中央金属杆，就像树干一样，
with smaller clothesline supports that branch out from the top. And then this thing sits in backyards and it spins slowly in the breeze, drying clothes on a series of lines that just sort of circle that central pole. And where is the hillswurst from? The hillshoast was developed in Australia
带有从顶部伸出的较小的晾衣绳支撑。然后这个东西放在后院，它在微风中缓慢旋转，在围绕那个中心杆的一系列绳子上干燥衣服。希尔斯升降机来自哪里？希尔斯升降机是在澳大利亚开发的，
and pioneered by this guy in the 1940s who's coming back from the war and decided to basically build his own backyard rotary clothesline. And it wasn't the first of its kind, but his really took off. They became a commercial success, and now that company sells millions of the things every year. This is not just a thing for drying clothes in your backyard.
由这个人在20世纪40年代开创，他从战争中回来，决定基本上建造他自己的后院旋转晾衣绳。它不是同类产品中的第一个，但他的确实火了。它们取得了商业成功，现在那家公司每年销售数百万个这种东西。这不仅仅是一个在后院晾衣服的东西。
Like this is become an iconic design that's really tied to Australia. Yeah. One of our listeners wrote in with a really great, very detailed explanation of its role in Australian culture. And basically, as she explains it, it's this kind of critical fixture of the suburban Australian dream. You get this quarter acre lot with a beautiful backyard, and in your beautiful backyard, you have this hill's hoist.
比如这已经成为一个与澳大利亚紧密相连的标志性设计。是的。我们的一位听众写了一封非常棒、非常详细的解释，说明了它在澳大利亚文化中的作用。基本上，正如她所解释的那样，它是澳大利亚郊区梦的一种关键固定装置。你得到这块四分之一英亩的地，有一个美丽的后院，在你的美丽后院里，你有这个希尔斯升降机。
And it's sort of an incomplete picture without that iconic thing. But unlike the single use case of the finished cabinet or even the Katatsu table, you see pictures of Hillshoy's being used as like things that kids hang on and spin around and pinyadas or whatever. Like anything that you can hang something and want to spin it, the Hillshoy's is the perfect solution for you. Yeah, and there's a great YouTube video out there of these guys who hooked up lines to the thing and a motor and have it spinning super fast and like there were whipping kids around
如果没有那个标志性的东西，它就是一幅不完整的画面。但与芬兰柜子或甚至炬燵桌的单一用例不同，你看到希尔斯升降机被用作孩子们挂在上面旋转、皮纳塔（pinyatas）之类的东西的照片。比如任何你可以挂东西并想旋转它的东西，希尔斯升降机都是你的完美解决方案。是的，网上有一个很棒的YouTube视频，这些人把绳子连到这个东西上，还有一个马达，让它转得超级快，就像他们在地上把孩子们甩在水滑梯上一样。如果有一个婚礼或节日派对，你会装饰你的希尔斯升降机。有一个喝酒游戏，人们把葡萄酒袋挂在上面并旋转它们。我喜欢它的一点是，对于你生命的每个阶段，都有一些你做的活动，无论你是挂在上面的孩子，还是年纪大得多、坐在你放在上面的遮阳结构里的人，每个人都有某种用途。
on a water slide on the ground. And if there's like a wedding or a holiday party, you decorate your Hills hoist. There's a drinking game where people hang bags of wine from the thing and spend those around. And one of the things I kind of love about it is that for like every stage of your life, there is some activity that you do, whether you're a kid who's swinging on the thing or somebody who's much older and sitting in the shade structure that you put on top of the
对。所以如果你把这个物体的普遍性与坐在后院的无聊结合起来，你就会得到某种创造性的解决方案。是的。是的，所以，我的意思是，这就是重点。
thing, like everybody has some use for this. Right. So if you combine the ubiquity of this object with boredom of sitting in your backyard, you will get some kind of creative solution for something. Yes. Yeah. And so, I mean, that's the thing.
这是一个大东西，它就在那里。所以，不可避免地，人们会想出新的方法来使用它。除了挂衣服之外。所以向希尔斯升降机致敬。它是特别的东西。所以不可避免地，人们会想出新的方法来使用它，除了，你知道，挂衣服。所以向希尔斯升降机致敬。它是特别的东西。感谢艾丽莎·史蒂文斯让我们了解希尔斯升降机。如果你想看其中任何一个的照片，或者如果你有来自你家乡或州的区域性设计解决方案，我们很乐意听到。你可以在99pi.org联系我们。
It's this big thing, and it's there. And so, inevitably, people figure out new things to do with it. Besides hanging clothes. So, hats off to the hillswice. It's something special. And so inevitably people figure out new things to do with it besides, you know hanging close So that's off to the hills moist. It's something special Thanks to Alyssa Stevens for letting us know about the hills hoist If you want to see pictures of any of these or if you have a regional design solution from your home country or state We'd love to hear about it. You can reach us and 99pi dot org
关于它，你可以在99pi.org联系我们。《99%隐形》本周由库尔特·科尔斯塔德、基蒂·明格尔和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德莱尼·霍尔、泰兰·马扎、肖恩·里亚尔、艾弗里·特罗尔、安·安瑟里、伊夫·尤西夫。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在广播街制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@99PI，或者在Instagram、Reddit、
about it. You can reach us at 99pi.org. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Kurt Colestead, Kitty Mingle, and me Roman Mars. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Terran Mazza, Sean Rial, Avery Troll from An Ancery, If You Sif. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI at work or on Instagram, Reddit,
和Tumblr上也可以。但在99pi.org上，关于在路标上描绘车道结束的最佳方式仍然存在激烈的争论。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
and Tumblr too. But there's still a raging debate about the best way to depict a lane ending on a road sign at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有Tumblr。但关于如何在路标上描绘车道终点的最佳方式，99pi.org上仍存在激烈的争论。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。